welcome to mle Cruz collaborating with
quto my name is Will Shu I'm going to be
presenting with my colleagues Susan
McMillan and Mike
Zen this is our mle
crew pictured on the right is the
director of our office and a drummer uh
Mike Fleer who's not able to join us
today uh we are a team of analysts for
the liberal arts college at the
University of Wisconsin Madison we
analyze student outcomes for
administration and faculty and an
important thing to know about us is that
none of us are data scientists or
developers we work in a collaborative
environment where our different types of
analyses and professional backgrounds
often contribute to a single analytic
product and our backgrounds
are I'm a
historian Susan's a political scientist
and Mike is a
philosopher uh I conduct mainly
Narrative analyses of curriculum and
University academic policy uh I'm also a
primary editor and uh I've been writing
in markdown for
years as we began to work together and
increased our collaboration we quickly
realized that we had a significant
problem and our problem was that we had
fragmented
workflows so every time that we
attempted a collaborative analysis uh we
were dealing with an assemblage of data
that was obtained using query tools like
Hyperion and Toad data point and SQL
Developer that we then analyzed using
Excel or R is the situation called for
we plotted it we merged it with
narrative analyses that were written uh
and drawn from Flat files that were
stored in obsidian or other
pkms uh and then that we tailored
together in
word published as a PDF because my
goodness do people like their
PDFs and then we distributed to our
audiences via
email this workflow we quickly realized
was
unsustainable we needed to find a better
way for us to work together keep in mind
also this is happening um after our
university has gone remote during Co and
so we're each working remotely we don't
have an opportunity to meet together to
do these things we have to unite our
work in some way so what we're going to
talk to you is how we abandoned this and
what we learned as we came to a new way
of working together I'm going to share
with you why the form of the work
matters Susan's going to speak about how
our new way of working together reduced
barriers for the non-technical
collaborators that we
have and Mike's going to share with you
how this new way has en enhanced the
accuracy of the work that we do
so why does form
matter I'm going to use some visual
metaphors here that are from the local
area production hurdles at the end of a
long analytic project are mentally
exhausting and they can be very
frustrating as I shared we were
assembling draft and final analytic
products um by merging analyses that
were drawn from different areas into a
word
document and we quickly quickly realized
that like the James R Thompson Center
which you see here P pictured here you
could visit uh a short walk down West
Randolph from where we are this became a
maintenance nightmare for us every
single time that we were asked to add a
plot what we when we realized that we
needed to edit a caption or when we
thought you know what this section of
this analysis really belongs somewhere
else because it amplifies a message that
we need our audiences to
get it was a maintenance nightmare we
Revisited it every single time that we
had one of
those you may be familiar with the adage
form follows function this comes from a
principle of design that was Advanced by
Le Sullivan who's a prominent Chicago
School architect Sullivan went so far as
to say that form following function was
a law of human
design you can see his ethos in many
buildings that he uh designed around
Chicago this is the auditorium building
which you can visit in a short walk down
Michigan Avenue this photo was taken in
1890 about a year after the building was
completed and with respect to Sullivan
who was certainly at the Forefront of
his field when the 19th century turned
to the 20th century we realized that for
folks who do the kind of work that we
and many of you do this simply doesn't
go far
enough and so what we'd suggest instead
is that the form of the work is its
function like the John Hancock Center
the structure of the analysis that we
create in our new way of working
together is visible in the final
analytic product it's visible to us on
the back end when we're looking at the
source when we can see how we structured
the query when we can see the r code
that we used to analyze the data that we
obtained from our query when we can see
the comments that'll explain to us 7
months down the line when we've
forgotten why we queried things the way
that we did what we were trying to do
and the other things that we tried none
of that's visible to our audiences but
it's there and because we can more
easily accommodate other requests that
our audiences have that structure is
something that we can fall back on to do
our work better so the form of our final
analysis facilitates its function now
and the function of producing our
analysis fashion its final form how did
we get
there we realized we had to embrace
Conway's law Melvin Conway is a computer
scientist and he suggested that the any
organization that attempts to design a
product or a system is going to
inevitably in some way replicate that
organization structure within that
product the example is if you have a
four person group working on something
and you need to build a bypass you're
going to have a four a four component
bypass that's the basic concept and what
we realized is that we have disparate
backgrounds that draw on different
analytic Styles and we needed to find a
way to bring those together we needed to
unify the production environment for our
analyses and we needed to unify our
workflow and so that's what we did we
adopted a unified workflow that allows
us to leverage our studio and quto as
the single place where we now query
process analyze and visualize data for
for our audiences and where we write our
narrative analyses and our executive
summaries that we can share with those
audiences to help them make sense of the
data that we've given them because we're
working often times remotely and in
different places from each other and
we're working on different components of
the analysis it's really important that
we have Version Control you may use
GitHub for Version Control we use gitlab
for our Version Control so that when I'm
working on doing some copy editing in a
nearly final draft and Mike and Susan
are TW speaking plots or doing some
other things maybe accommodating a last
minute request from a stakeholder um
we're not getting in each other's way
and we're not having to recompile a PDF
document to incorporate those
changes and once we've reached the point
where our document is finished and we
feel like the the analysis is ready to
share with our audiences we can publish
it online using the pages feature of
gitlab and our audiences can view the
document there and if we have other
things that need to be updated it can be
updated
now Susan's going to share with you how
this new workflow has reduced technical
barriers for our
collaborators yeah thanks will Susan
McMillan I am the social scientist in
our group and despite many years of
writing scripted code for multiple
software packages I I embody the
non-technical user computers still are
mysterious to me I don't know any
markdown I didn't even I never heard of
markdown actually I didn't know what a
CSS file was I worked in a company
before I came to this job where we did
that painful copy paste process for
every document we produced analytic
document and it could be a really big
document but I produced a table or a
graph or text and I gave it to the
document production team and the
document production team put all the
disparate pieces together and then they
s shipped it out to the client
we are the document production team now
we're also the analysis team we're
everything so this was not tenable so
when I got here Mike was our kind of our
our studio missionary and he said no
we're going to go we're going to do this
in our markdown I was like okay so I
started learning our markdown which was
probably a little bit painful for Mike
because we were still producing PDF
files and so I also had to learn a
little bit of latch which was completely
mysterious but we were trying and then
uh the our studio conference last year
we were introduced to quto we're like
well there it is so we went home and
very rapidly um turned our process into
one that begins and ends with our studio
and CTO and um this is what happened we
are able to use the techn the visual
editor so the point of this slide is
only in the top corner with the the
switch the toggle between Visual and
source code and the table is there but
the point here is that it's familiar
enough to people who use word or some
other word processor but we'll just go
with word that they can do things in
this file so our supervisor who's our
expert at both policy and curriculum
needs to be able to write and edit in
our documents and he's able to do that
here he's able to see oh if I want a
bold text I can do it if I want to
italicize text I can do it if I want to
add a b list I can do that so he doesn't
want to learn r or R markdown and
frankly he's a little bit afraid of
seeing the code like I might put the
table in like this he doesn't want to
see that right he wants to see just this
and it works for both of us same file
and as will said we can
now publish our results to web pages
mind you the only point of this slide is
that I published it as a web page
I don't know HTML I don't know anything
about
publications I just pushed it to get lab
and it was magically there so that's the
whole point of this slide that I was
able to do it and so quto reduced
massively the technical barriers it's
not a chance I could have published a
website on my own um well it would have
taken a lot but I mean yeah so that's
the point of this whole slide we're now
able to publish to web pages and our
education people love their PDF files
but we kind of cold turkeyed them we
just sent out here the reports are going
to be on web pages now and it worked the
one of the other benefits to us is that
we can control access to our reports now
we used to just send out a PDF file and
there it goes right uh every now and
then we go to a meeting and people are
clutching printed versions but um now we
can update right I'm sure it's happened
to you you send out a PDF report and you
find some kind of critical error and
then you have to republish it and resend
it and now you have a Version Control
problem now quto and and publ Publishing
via get lab solves that problem for us
in addition our users get improved
functionality right we have in our
College I don't even know how many
majors 60s something majors and a lot of
our tables are long because it's buy
major buy this buy that in a PDF you're
you know Pages later now we can have our
users sort by column and this table
doesn't particularly have um
searchability but we can they can search
and so Deans might have a different
question for example from a faculty
member in a department they can sort the
table or search the table for the
particular piece of information they're
looking for without having having to
Rifle through pages of PDF output so
despite their reluctance to embrace some
non-pdf format it's been a really good
thing for us because we've literally
unified our workflow we can all work in
the same file and our users get improved
functionality whether they wanted it or
not and Mike is going to talk about a
few other
enhancements okay so um I'm going to
talk about accuracy and so one thing
about me is six years ago I was teaching
ethics had never written a line of R
code um I've written quite a bit since
then but um no formal development
training I you know I've run Linux at
home but you know that's about it um and
so um what I want to say here is you can
improve accuracy without being a
developer essentially so to do that um
I'm going to talk about a little example
um so let's imagine that Susan and I are
each given a task to produce report
about that involves in some way computer
science majors and we need to know how
many there were in 2019 and 2020 right
these might be separate reports
sometimes we do reports apart from each
other don't talk to each other and what
happens God forbid we come up with
different numbers oh no this is
embarrassing it's bad so Susan comes up
with
2,266 I come up with
2,389 right this could affect funding
for these departments it could affect
the analysis right because there's
different students I it seems in these
and it is you know again really
embarrassing so I'm going to go through
this little example just to show you how
you might solve some of these um
problems of um accuracy so why is this
happening okay so the reason in this
case is because the um term or semester
data is coded in our system right I'm
sure you have lots of codes in your work
in this case it's a four-digit code so
for instance 1204 is spring
2020 what a great code um so this is how
it works so um the century is the first
one so zero is the 20th century one is
the 21st century um the uh second two
digits are the last two digits of the
year um but this is not the academic
year or the calendar year and this is
actually going to come up as an issue
right so I'm not sure what this is It's
a year um and then the last digit is
fall spring summer right two four and
six which you know I think they were
thinking what if there's a winter term
someday we want to have room for it so
there you go
246 um I love codes okay so what's
happening here so this is ambiguity and
Academic Year is the reason why we came
up with different numbers so an academic
year and this is a federal uh I think
it's Federal it's Federal definition
it's certainly for our reporting um runs
from Summer to spring so um the 2019
2020 uh Academic Year is um from Summer
of 2019 to Spring 2020 right I see I'm
the wrong one of course um I was
thinking the codes were going to help me
the codes are never helpful right so I
was looking oh look there's 20 2020
that's the night 2019 2020 Academic Year
it's not of course um and so I was
unaware of the correct way to defined
Academic Year and so that's why um I
came up with the incorrect answer so how
do we fix this of course packages okay
so for you that's obvious yeah um I
don't need to talk too much about
packages but my point here is that I
believe anyone can write them so I
believe this is just a belief I have
that if you can write a function and yes
you can write a function I think anyone
who can write our code can write a
function then you can write a package
and
furthermore you can share them via
GitHub or gitlab and that allows for
easy installation and updates so if I
update a package um now Susan or will
can download that new version and all of
our reports change automatically with a
fix you know there are sometimes fixes
um so we have one package that call
called am utils it has um a function
called aad year and you know if you just
type it in you get transparently the
code that goes into it right this is
ugly rcode but um you can just see it
it's there um it's great for learning so
if we have a new analyst they can now
see how this process is done you can get
um documentation for this and this is
the ugly stuff you have in our studio I
think it's beautiful but um you know you
can also produce beautiful websites with
documentation and organize them you get
indices right that show you all the
functions that are involved in here um
and so Academic Year is a really simple
function it just converts a term to
Academic Year but we have some complex
functions that actually took a long time
to figure out and are difficult when
doing onboarding with new people and so
this allows us to do that so finally um
you can have different types of um
packages so we have two types so one is
public so the amils has a ulous stuff
like aad year you know things that um
you know don't sort of expose any data
or anything um or any sort of
proprietary information we also have an
aim queries package that has queries in
them that allow you to access our campus
databases and that requires you to sort
of credential a bit um behind you know
in gitlab so we're able to separate
those into two different packages okay
so we want you to make your mle Career
Success just well I hope we're kind of
EX successed I don't know um so here
here's how we do it adopt the unified
workfl um so we're now querying to
publication in a single environment um
it's really exciting for us
so draw non-technical users with um you
know our studio visual editor and also
the online publication features of
GitHub and gitlab and finally please use
packages you know it is a great feature
of R it is amazing they allow for
accurate consistent well documented
processes and you know we should all be
using them for so many things okay so
thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you very
much um I'm going to combine two of
these questions here uh first part is do
people still print your HTML reports yes
and a few sorry yeah they look fine
though actually it's they do yeah
follow-up
question do you give them only the HTML
or do you use quarter to sort of produce
an HTML and a uh PDF from the same thing
okay no no we just it here's the link
and we repeat that answer here's the
link here's how you can engage with the
data which is something that you can't
do on this piece of paper but I kind of
want to now after seeing that uh that
new uh non latch thing that thing was
amazing types I kind of want to so maybe
we'll put buttons in there I don't know
um okay
um right there seems to be some local
people in the audience
did you guys crash any of the modules of
stat
327 um which is apparently your
University's or class at any point or
did you first pick up our
independently uh on the job on the job
yeah I totally on the job we taught
oursel I I taught myself really badly um
a lot of bass art but then I came to
2019 conference and it changed my entire
perspective on things so this is a great
resource
yeah okay um um so this one here leans a
little bit into uh something that I also
had been curious about so the question
is very specific do you integrate learn
at um
wanvis data into your analytics as well
as campus data um and yeah which I find
interesting because I was
wondering what is the thing you're
working with you told us a lot about
your workflow if you want to take the
opportunity to tell us something about
your work in general please take it uh
so we primarily if we're looking at
student outcomes we're analyzing data
from our degree audit system which is
you know essentially final grades for
students and their performance over the
entirety of their academic careers
things that are captured in the learning
management system and we use canvas um
are not things that we typically
incorporate because those belong to the
instructors if an instructor shares that
with us then yes of course right if they
have a specific question about their
class so things students do yeah all
right thank you very much um we have one
more speaker so thank you for this
[Applause]
presentation